j'avais dit que je mettrai pas en ligne
cette vidéo vous avez été nombreux à me
demander de la m quand même que
finalement vous m'avez convaincu
justement tu aurais pas dû la mettre
terme tabou choix jeu comment ils vont
alors s'il ya bien une personne légitime
pour parler de style je pense que c'est
moi attention je suis dégoûté parce que
je réalise que je suis né pour avoir un
look banal tous les trucs un peu style
et exubérant sur moi font ridicule les
doc marteens sur moi ça fait pape sy
comptable un bob sur moi ça fait
pêcheurs du dimanche
les mèches blondes ça fait touche la
moustache ça fait ch bon en fait sur moi
tout foetus quoi moi quand j'étais petit
je pensais qu'il y avait un endroit
j'aurai un bureau quelque part ou où des
gens décider des modes bon la question
l'enceinte avait content tu nous
rappelles fonctionnement ouais bah comme
d'hab rappeurs portent une fringue tout
le monde va être originale en faisant la
même chose c'est-à-dire has been
hélas est venu chercher voilà alors
qu'est ce que vous proposez là alors
cette année je propose de relancer les
charentaises mais les charentaises of
wight pas pour moi c'est aussi bien que
de la diarrhée en fait tu te fous de ma
gueule tu veux la boîte est cool quoi je
te rappelle le des meilleures idées
ouais nan mais à l'époque j'étais en
stage et sans compter la connerie qui a
lancé il ya deux ans je crois que tout
le monde s'en rappelle
ouais après j'étais en dépression oui
après on n'oublie pas que ça toi aussi
qui a lancé la marque streetwear
mais bon ça va on a compris pourra-t-on
piscine on refait des colas va faire
gucci geox louis vuitton en quechua
gilbert chollet
[Musique]
quoi à tomber c'est une pure idée ça tu
vois un t-shirt ironique
genre tu portes un truc vieux des huées
ringard et du coup ça devient un stylet
ouais comme les t-shirts jacques chirac
ou céline dion
non et c'est sympa c'est pas ironique ah
j'aime vraiment bien ce t-shirt mais au
delà des modes vestimentaires
on dirait que en 2019 ça y est tout le
monde est atouts et ses limites la norme
même les mannequins quand tu vas sur le
site de fringues dhorasoo c'est tout tu
regardes les modèles le mec super
mannequin espagne man parfois les gens
ils sont tatoués pendant un voyage
limites qu'on dirait que plus tu as toi
g été fait à l'arraché au bout du monde
plus et stylé mec je me suis fait
tatouer la main dans un petit boui boui
en inde sur un coup de tête bourride
entre potes stade élire par trouver un
mec et ça donne quoi
bath infectés je vais me faire amputer
dans deux jours un programme en moignon
et bouge on dirait que les gens à tous
et ils ont toujours une histoire à
raconter sur chacun de leurs tatouages
et on dirait que c'est obligatoire qui a
un rapport avec la famille
ouais j'ai un tatouage ouais mais ça un
peu personnel je sais pas si j'ai envie
d'en parler moi je te dis en fait c'est
en hommage à ma grand mère j'ai
directement fait tatouer son
déambulateur
je devais faire aussi son dentier mais
j'avais plus de thunes parce que la base
je suis graphiste je suis payé en
bitcoin mamie si je me fais un tatouage
un jour j'ai trop peur de choisir un
truc qui est plus à la mode
trois mois plus tard et quelques temps
j'ai fait de tatouages j'ai fait un hand
szpiner et un mec qui dab g g le seul
vrai moi quand quelqu'un veut me faire
faire du shopping ça me fait très
plaisir tant parce que ça fait genre
avec des dents mais faire du shopping
mode tag est ça va ah non là je
t'emmènerai de shopping la sacra web est
qu un pote va au bout du délire essaie
de me conseiller en fringues pas ça se
voit en fait voilà en gros c'est comment
elle est maintenant là c'est génial et
ben voilà on a enfin un mec appelle-moi
de dany 2 il ya des gens qui sont
obsédés par les marques de frei il ya
vraiment que ça qui compte pas du tout
le reste du vêtement je ne sais pas
un tee shirt alors les sneakers
parlons-en
bon c'est du basket mais vous faut dire
sneakers moi j'ai trop de potes qui
collectionne les sneakers
c'est vraiment leur passion mais pas moi
personnellement je m'en bats les
couilles
par contre du coup je collectionne les
potes qui collectionne les sneakers
quand ils parlent de leurs choses on
dirait des historiens ça c'est le modèle
édition collector des 20 ans de la tn
hot chilli orange d'un côté aux types de
l'autre c'est magnifique the grid
grillage déçu c'est trop beau monde
vas-y mais les mecs ça tu m'aider mais
tout fous toi bats pas tu connais rien
en basket en fait corps bref tout ce que
vous racontez est totalement superficiel
ou c'est important c'est d'être situé à
l'intérieur plutôt qu'à l'extérieur on
peut avoir un style différent se
côtoyaient voir ses mécènes c'est pas
parce que t'as pas même ses
cocontractants la prochaine fois qu'on
sort on tape sur tout si on va chez
darty
[Applaudissements]
ah merci d'avoir visionné ce contenu
vidéoludique j'espère que c'était pas
trop relou mais fallait que je le disais
fallait que ça sorte tel du pus dans un
bouton d'acné
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]